l'Élysée pour la première fois
depuis 1968. Notre correspondant
à Paris, Raphaël Bouvier-
Auclair, y était.
- Nous vous faisons commandeur
de la Légion d'honneur.
- Dans un salon de l'Élysée,
un grand honneur rendu à
Antonine Maillet dont letstststs
sont emblématiques de l'Acadie.
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président, de la France
- Alors certains bâtissent
des cathédrales pierre a pierre,
e e e e vos aïeux. Vous, c'est
de page en page, d'oeuvre
en oeuvre que vous rebâtissez
la mémoire, l'imaginaire et la
langue que le grand dérangement
aurait pu oblitérer.
- Déjà membre de la légion
d'honneur, l'Acadienne est
élevée au rang de commandeur.
Pour la femme de 92 ans,
il s'agit d'une reconnaissance
supplémentaire en France
où elle a étprprprprprésenté
plusieurs de ses oeuvres.
L'écrivaine a été la première
non européenne à obtenir le prix
Goncourt en 1979 pour son livre
Pé-C-C-C-C-Charrette.
Selon la créatrice
de "La Sagouine", la perception
qu'ont les français de l'Acadie
a beaucoup changé
avec les décennies.
Antonine Maillet, écrivaine
- Une énorme transformation,
une énorme transformation.
Autrefois, beaucoup de Français
ne savaient pas que l'Acadie
existait.
- Une transformation à laquelle
elle a grandement contribué.
Mais Antonine Maillet a rappelé
que pour défendre sa langue et
sa culture, le combat n'est pas
terminé.
ANTONINE MAILLET
- Je tiens à vou
pour que vous soyez rassurés;
qu'aussi longtemps que
ma génération sera là,
que les gens de mon métier
seront là et que les gens qui
partagent mes ambitions seront
là, eh bien, on ne lâchera pas,
mais en vous demandant
en retour : aidez-nous.
- Vous avez fait réexister
tous ces combats, humbles
si déterminés et si essentiels.
- Le consulat français
de Moncton était menacé.
Le président l'admet, une lettre
que lui a fait parvenir
Antonine Maillet l'a rapidement
convaincu de le préserver.
Pour elle, la France
et l'Acadie doivent continuer
de tisser des liens.
- Moi, j'attends beaucoup du
président. D'abord
qu'il vienne en Acadie,
et il a des chances de venir
en Acadie, parce que nous fêtons
ces années-ci. En l'an 2024,
on A A A A A A A Alors j'attends
du président qu'il ait un oeil
sur l'Acadie qui est distinct
de celui qu'il a sur le Québec
ou le reste du Canada.cococococn
venue de chez elle pour
recevoir cette décoration,
Antonine Maillet a certainement
contribué à mettre l'accent
sur cette relation
transatlantique.
- Alors aujourd'hui,
j'ai l'impression de faire
un geste que mes ancêtres
préparaient depuis tant
d'années.
- En France, il y a désormais
le symbole de l'arbre planté
en compagnie du président
sur le terrain de l'Élysée
qui témoigne notamment
de décennies d'efforts pour
mieux permettre à la culture
acadienne de s'enracin
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, Paris.